you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean they all
die fighting spider-man it's their fate
they're a danger to our universe
you're not gonna take this away from me
you're struggling damn everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save everyone
welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new spider-man no way home sinister 6 video i
know you all have questions about who the sixth
member of the team is because there are only
five that we see in the trailer that we know of
very misleading these marvel trailers you
can't totally trust everything that you see
there was a recent clip that was released that
i think reveals what's going on with that sixth
member so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets
all you have to do to enter just be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about who the sixth
member of the team is going to be on the video
so you've all probably seen the spider-man no way
home trailer a billion more times since yesterday
alone but there's still been a lot of questions
about what's actually going on with the sinister
six in the movie in the sinister five of it
all because like i said we only see five actual
members of the team on screen in the trailer
footage they're very prominent like they really
want you to think that this is the whole team but
it's not called the sinister five it's called the
sinister six and marvel wouldn't roll this hard
on sinister six tropes spider-man vs sinister six
from the comics to not actually put a sixth
member of the team in the movie in some way
the way they're actually doing the sinister
six their actual story in the movie is much
twistier than you would expect it's not meant
to be a straight up spider-man vs the sinister
six kind of story but they're kind of pitching it
that way from the trailer footage but thanks to a
recent clip with michael keaton it seems like he
just confirmed that he's going to be the sixth
member of the team as vulture here's the clip
of him talking about getting ready to film new
vulture scenes he also talks a little bit about
doing new batman stuff briefly during this too
i'm shooting tomorrow i'm shooting you shooting
tomorrow yeah man what are you shooting tomorrow
some vulture stuff yo your vulture tomorrow
all right i didn't go hey who else is what
other guys you're gonna be at you didn't say that
no because here's how bad it is i'll show up and
i'll go i'll be like and then i'll go hey uh what
point does uh does spider-man show up or something
and they'll say and i go you know when does
hulk come in i showed up on one of the when i
played vulture which was really a fun character
i gotta say and uh and i s they have to brief
they have to brief me and i see it in their
eyes they're going uh so you know when um
and then they'll say when you did blah blah and
then you know your character tombs came in and
he did that thing remember because earlier than
spider-man and i'm going right right i'm thinking
i have no idea who's who or why or where even
where i am i'm sure kevin feige is probably
going to be giving him a phone call about that
kevin feige been making a lot of those kinds of
phone calls to actors in spider-man noway home
recently especially with jamie foxx kind of
confirming that there would be multiple versions
of spider-man in the movie just yesterday after
the trailer came out thank you very much electro
for confirming that he kind of did that way back
when they announced his character too last year
like we've known for a while now that there were
going to be multiple versions of spider-man but
what michael keaton is talking about in that clip
is how he's in two different multiverse movies and
it's just totally confusing for him as an actor
spider-man no way home is a very spider-verse type
of multiverse movie he's also in the morbius movie
which i'll talk about in a second because that's
important for what's happening with the vulture in
spider-man no way home especially after what they
did with venom in the venom look to be carnage
post-credits scene but keaton is also in the flash
movie playing a multiverse version of batman so
it's kind of the same concept so that's why he was
joking about the producers of both of these movies
the spider-man no way home the marvel people
in the flash movie dc people having to brief
him on the continuity every single time he goes
in to film new scenes for these different movies
the example he gave was the spider-man no
way home producers having to remind him
what happened to vulture at the end of spider-man
homecoming and then during the morbius movie
and the big sinister six arc in the movie
is all about testing spider-man's character
that's why he has this big moral conflict with
doctor strange in the movie spider-man vs doctor
strange is a fight over morality if you've seen
all the clips recently of tom hall and talking
about the movie he basically said his spider-man
will always try to save people even the villains
and doctor strange is trying to send the sinister
six characters back to their original universes
which means sending them to their deaths as both
he and doctor octopus tell him during the trailer
so that's why spider-man yoinks doctor strange's
box with a symbol of the vishanti on it it's the
same symbol that's on all the sanctums and the eye
of agamotto on the box and the enchantment on it
is probably what doctor strange is trying to use
to send the sinister six characters back so part
of what's going on in their arc all these sinister
six scenes in the movie is that spider-man is
trying to save them save the villains but also
trying to stop them from destroying the main mcu
reality like they're trying to kill him mj and ned
leeds while he's trying to save them and what does
that remind you of it's exactly the way they ended
spider-man homecoming with spider-man fighting the
vulture to stop him but also fighting to save his
life time to go home pete i'm trying to save you
so they're doing that again during spider-man
no way home wouldn't it make sense to bring the
vulture back again for that vulture already
did him a solid in the spider-man homecoming
post-credits scene when scorpion teased that
sinister six team up vulture pretends to not
know his secret identity but mysterio
kinda threw that concept out the window
still though vulture owes spider-man his life so
i think the idea is what the wind up showing us
is that different versions of spider-man in
saving some of the villains lives like toby
maguire saving doctor octopus's life in spider-man
2 and tom holland doing the same thing for vulture
karma comes back around and some of those villains
in the movie will help spider-man defeat the other
sinister six characters without having to kill
them it also ties into the whole great power
great responsibility speech the classic spider-man
speech tom holland himself actually quoted this
at the recent event where they revealed the
trailer and we have a responsibility to do
the right thing and help out our neighbor and
look after one another and that's exactly what
spider-man stands for so with great power comes
great responsibility you do kind of wonder if
they're going to actually say that in the movie
just because they tried to avoid doing the same
spider-man tropes in every single film like that's
why they avoided doing uncle ben during spider-man
homecoming but in my video yesterday i talked
about doctor octopus's arc during the movie
where it actually seems like based on some of the
later trailer footage it seems like he's actually
working with spider-man trying to fight the other
sinister six characters because you see elektro
fighting him like blasting him with his lightning
out this window here a lot of you probably
also had this theory too like doctor octopus
actually being a good character during the film
because of his arc during spider-man 2
in them not wanting to trample on that
if his story in spider-man no way home is meant to
pick up right after the end of spider-man 2 at the
end of spider-man 2 he redeemed himself by trying
to save the city by pulling his reactor down
into the east river sacrificing his life in the
process but doctor strange's spell and spider-man
messing it up effectively bringing him back
to life by yoinking him from across space-time
so even though you see a lot of scenes of doctor
octopus just giving spider-man the business
it does sound like at some point he starts
to help him like they find some common ground
after all the joking about his name that is
pretty funny to see spider-man joking about
his name otto octavius but looking at all the
willem dafoe green goblin the electro the sandman
the lizard scenes it just seems like some of the
other sinister six characters get backed into a
corner and they're fighting spider-man thinking
that they're fighting for their lives so i think
they're trying to do a little more character
development for them in the movie like it's
not just about them wanting to kill spider-man
because they hate spider-man they're actually
fighting for their lives legit like you can't
send us home because we're gonna die if we go home
in the whole idea that doctor strange is basically
giving them that you don't have to go home but you
definitely can't stay here kind of speech like
you're a danger to the main mcu universe so you
cannot stay here but just based on the way they
in the trailer with that tag scene just setting
up doctor strange 2 it seems like they do find
some temporary solution to this multiverse problem
but that solution just creates larger problems for
doctor strange with reality crumbling around them
that he'll have to solve during doctor strange
two multiverse of madness like yay we've saved
all the sinister six characters lives in most of
my friends lives and successfully contained them
but in doing so they doom the main mcu universe
quick spoiler warning for the eternals movie too
this is kind of the way they ended the eternals
movie where they do wind up saving the earth they
saved the day but in doing so they kind of doomed
the planet to judgment from the other celestials
and airshown the judge like they kill a celestial
and now they have tiamet basically turned to stone
in the indian ocean just jutting out from earth
so big that you can see him from outer space
nick fury's one eye is probably rolling into
the back of his head up in a space station just
watching this all play out but i think the idea
with the timeline is that this happens with the
eternals over on this side of the plant like over
in the indian ocean on the other side of the earth
right before spider-man doctor strange in the
sinister six characters crack all of reality
like you see it crumbling around them and the
multiverse starts bleeding into the main mcu
universe in a really big way so spider-man
no way home eternals and doctor strange 2
all kind of overlap just a little bit but what
is the end of spider-man no way home mean for
the future of the sinister six characters because
if you guys have seen the news the past couple of
months sony is basically working up to another
new spin-off sinister six franchise the way that
they were trying to do during the andrew garfield
amazing spider-man movies so what they might wind
up doing at the end of spider-man no way home is
just dedicating a small scene at the end to just
let you know where they might take that without
necessarily pinning themselves into a corner
the same way that the venom let there be carnage
scene only implied where their plot might go
like it sounds like venom is going to be fighting
spider-man in a future movie but they didn't tell
you exactly how that's going to play out everyone
let me know in the comments though what do you
think about vulture being the sixth member of the
sinister six team and also helping out spider-man
defeat them just like doctor octopus is a member
of the team but winds up switching sides and
helping spider-man during the movie big reminder
that hawkeye episodes start next week they're
actually going to drop the first two episodes on
day one so i'll post my videos for both of those
next wednesday when they release them i've got
a couple of the big spider-man videos that i'm
working on just leave all your requests
your big questions in the comments below
everyone click here to watch the spider-man
no way home trailer a billion more times
and click here to learn about that
mystery andrew garfield spider-man scene
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!